I just picked out a question from there
we're going to do this now I am as the
question just I'm going to show you I
think but as we do it if you have
another color there let me have it ready
because I'll put the psyche as we solve
the question I'm going to make some
suggestions and point out do it online
that will help you solve these thank you
okay so after you've got the question
down there can I encourage you to write
the question every time you do a
question don't just go straight to your
first line of working the reason for
that is the same reason why we draw
diagrams when you draw a diagram
you understand the diagram etta when you
write the question the process of
writing the question down helps to
cement it in your mind okay and also
avoid trans between my fellow people so
third thing when you're multiplying
fractions of any kind
we found your up or without your just
multiply across the top and across the
bottom okay keep that in mind I'm
actually going to write over here enough
first you multiply numerators and
denominators the reason why I put this
out is because instead of doing this
don't write this but just watch it some
students look at a question like this
and instead of multiplying numerators
and numerators and denominators with
denominator that they say oh wait two
fractions I don't know what to do with
these I'm going to cross multiply and
I'm going to get both edges because
crosswalks point is cool a good cross
multiplying that's not what you do when
do you cross multiply you're supposed to
cuss a lot by sometimes just not now
when
what are we thinking of when we try and
do that many suggestions when there is
an equation so example maybe you want to
write this one on the side if I gave you
this
there we go
I gave you that again a pair of
fractions right this time because
multiplying makes sense what Christmas
like really is doing is multiplying both
sides by 3 it's an equation or the fun
so keep it balanced but in addition to 3
x 21 because then you get rid of both
denominators
okay in fact make that happen did you do
this and that's great
this is not equation though it's a
multiplication it's a product so you do
not cross multiply multiply numerators
enzyme is in fact such a big deal
secondly I'd like you to write do not
cross multiply because it's a product
not an equation systems like the ones
that are at the bottom of five minutes
deep and then like the top would be to
do yes I'm coming to that competition so
when you have a look at this right
multiplying in the correct direction is
the first thing done don't cross
multiply you know it's a product not an
equation this is the reason but a better
thing to do first
once you're just get the basic concept
is to see if you can cancel anything can
we make the fractions simpler before you
put them together and the answer is in
this case there's always one thing we
can do to make being a block and what
can we do are two things to two things
what do you see on the top you can
cancel from the body are good
suggestions okay find B and 10 be like
remember since we multiply across the
top and I'm like in right this is your
next time
what should really guys just one
gigantic fraction in 6 times 10 be on
the top see I multiply the numerators
and 5 v times 18 on the bottom of the
column multiply the denominators so be
that really is one fraction you can just
cancel
keep the way we encourage you to do that
get another color and then under the
line don't cross out underline the
things that are in common
can you it's just why I prefer not to
cross things out as you cancel
suggestion feel the or than diamond
wonderful that way if you want to trace
back and check your work you like going
to be you're working is just a mess of
crossed out things and the market can
see what you're doing as well so that's
the first thing
is there anything else you can see that
will be in common with your lighting six
and eighteenth sort of simple six I mean
what without leaving with down the
bottom three it's all the fire to the
temperature I'm going to put a box
around this this which will leave me
with what at the top to the one-time to
you yes sir that's correct that's
correct
okay so I've identified all the things
that I think every right so what's left
on the top really didn't we do something
with that base it's pretty quick here
those the biggest a way maybe ha ha ha
ha
get up Oh once I saw the bottom the
fire's gone the be gone in two three
lift frog TR that's it